zeitenwende ist ja das schlagwort dieser
bundesregierung olaf scholz war der
erste des verwendet und gesetzt hat und
das war als er in der sondersitzung des
bundestages nach kriegsausbruch
gesprochen hat stichwort olaf scholz
stichwort sprechen das ist ja so eine
sache viele sagen kann ich und viele
sagen er kann ass robert habeck
vizekanzler der stehe für eine
zeitenwende nämlich für eine zeitenwende
in der politischen kommunikation was hat
habe ich was scholz nicht hat ist das
fair dem einen vorzuwerfen er könne
keine kommunikation und den anderen über
den grünen klee zu loben ist das
wirklich so klar verteilt das redetalent
ich heiße in die politik mann bin
korrespondentin im zdf hauptstadtstudio
und sage herzlich willkommen zu unserer
neuen ausgabe von inside politics
preisfrage wie klingt und wie sieht ein
beleidigter spd bundeskanzler aus
antwort so willy brandt 1971 im gespräch
mit dem wdr journalistin friedrich nur
die währungsfrage die ungelöste
europäische währungsfrage das
schwierigste problem dieser konsultation
ja und sie haben den präsidenten keine
lösung von unserer seite aus mit auf dem
rückweg geben können doch haben sie ihm
die termine genannt so wichtig sind die
termine die festlegung des wechselkurses
der dem nein und sie sind sicher dass er
trotzdem beschädigt war ja brand kam ja
gerade aus deutsch französischen
regierungskonsultationen
und hatte so hat nowotny das später mal
erzählt das gefühl an einem bedeutenden
staatspolitischen ereignis teilgenommen
zu haben und deshalb sei er sehr
beleidigt gewesen als nowotny im kurz
vor dem interview sagte dass sie nur
eine minute 30 zur verfügung hätten
deshalb antwortete brand konsequent
einsilbig manche fühlten sich kürzlich
an dieses legendäre interview erinnert
deshalb deshalb robert habeck gibt jetzt
tipps zum sparen sagt irgendwie
vielleicht mal ein bisschen weniger
heizen vielleicht ein bisschen kürzer
duschen haben sie auch praktische
alltagstipps zu haben das kann man
vielleicht noch lustig finden anders
aber diese situation in der schweiz auf
die frage einer journalistin zum
abschluss des g 7 gipfels auch nicht
wirklich viel mehr sagte der
bundeskanzler die g 7 haben beginnen
bekannten sich sehr ausdrücklich zu den
sicherheitsgarantien für die ukraine
auch nach dem krieg könnten sie
konkretisieren welche
sicherheitsgarantien das sind ja
könnte ich
das war's okay
okay naja hier im berliner
regierungsviertel kann das zum beispiel
gar nicht gut an vor allem bei den
kolleginnen und kollegen in den anderen
sendern und redaktionen arroganz fanden
das viele holz habe die journalistin
abgebügelt die findet ihr so eine
antwort hanseatisch trocken witzig oder
völlig daneben zurück zum thema olaf
scholz und seinen reden interviews und
antworten das ist eben so eine sache
keine gute finden viele die deutsche
welle aus deren reihen übrigens die
journalistin stammte die scholz
abgebügelt hatte stellte deshalb neulich
die k frage kann der kanzler
kommunikation das habe ich ein profi
gefragt und ich sag mal so seine antwort
ist so deutlich da kann sich scholz eine
dicke scheibe von abschneiden
momentan haben auch nicht den eindruck
er spricht langsam suchen foto mitunter
er weicht auch gerne in interviews
fragen aus auch bei den
waffenlieferungen wirkte er eben wie so
ein getriebener dort gab es ständig
widersprüche so dass am ende eigentlich
gar nicht mehr wusste was er tatsächlich
möchte was die bundesregierung geben
auch möchte und das ist in so einer
situation wo die bevölkerung ja auch ein
bisschen orientierung und sicherheit
vermittelt bekommen möchte sicherlich
nicht hilfreich im momente in denen das
fragezeichen sehr dick und sehr groß
wird der bundeskanzler ich habe noch
nicht genau verstanden
ob deutschland nun schwere waffen
liefern wird oder nicht wir haben das
gemacht indem wir waffen unseren eigenen
beständen geliefert haben indem wir
jetzt mit der ukraine zusammen eine
industrie liste durchgegangen sind und
da ist es unsere absicht diese lieferung
zu bezahlen im übrigen ist es so dass
wenn die europäische union 1,5
milliarden euro für die finanzierung von
waffenlieferung bereitstellt dass sie
einen wesentlichen und zu einem großen
teil ein deutscher beitrag ist ansonsten
geht es um erhebliche
waffen mit erhebliche auswirkungen das
gilt schon für die die wir bisher
geliefert haben ob das nun panzer
abwehrsysteme flugabwehrsysteme sind ob
das bestandteile von artillerie sind die
man einsetzen kann was jetzt auch unsere
verbündeten und partner tun und in
diesem rahmen sind wir bereit dinge
möglich zu machen liefert deutschlands
wäre waffen an die ukraine ja oder nein
warum nicht warum auf einmal doch welche
waren was sind überhaupt schwere waffen
olaf scholz liefert nämlich verwirrende
ausweichende und widersprüchliche
antworten die manchmal nicht mal welche
zu sein scheinen auch deshalb nennt man
ihn den schweizer marken woran liegt das
kann er nicht anders oder villa nicht
anders wie ihr seht kann er durchaus
anders olaf scholz bei der ersten mai
kundgebung des deutschen
gewerkschaftsbundes in düsseldorf laut
sauer glasklar
das showformat scholzomat ohr wenn olaf
scholz also anders kann warum macht er
es dann so selten so anders also ich
glaube dass oder freut sich gerade in
der situation
befindet wo er versucht wieder zu
vermeiden er möchte eben nicht durch
unbedachte äußerungen jetzt hier
möglicherweise auch noch eine
internationale krise
heraufbeschwören er muss auch in seiner
partei die er durchaus auch den
waffenlieferungen kritisch gegenüber
steht die bevölkerung ist durchaus auch
da ja gespalten das kanzlers
krisenkommunikation ist also quasi noch
mal eine ganz eigene krise oder kürzer
scholz will fehler vermeiden und macht
deshalb fehler dabei macht es schon
anders als seine vorgängerin gibt mehr
interviews als angela merkel geht öfter
in talkshows als sie diesen podcast wie
sie hat er jetzt neuerdings auch noch
und ob aber es geht halt auch darum was
man sagt und nicht nur die oft die
kritik an scholz wird immer lauter und
dabei ist ein name die ganze zeit sehr
deutlich herauszuhören der von robert
habeck der ist quasi der antischall und
das würde ich jetzt auch vermuten ist
macht es höchste oder für uns sicherlich
noch schwerer und vielleicht auch ein
bisschen bitter war dass er eben in
seinem kabinett mindestens mit robert
haben und mit annalena baerbock kann
auch die außenministerin hat die leute
sicherlich sehr schön ja gelingender
kommunizieren und überzeugender
kommunizieren beck macht seine sache
kommunikativ dermaßen gut finden fehler
dass einige ihn schon als wanderndes hvv
olaf scholz bezeichnen oder aber von
scholz fordert er solle mehr harbeck
wagen die meisten von euch werden es
erkannt haben da er soll wieder der
willy brandt denn diese überschrift
dehnt sich an an eine seiner
kernbotschaft wir wollen mehr demokratie
was also macht habeck anders als scholz
kurz und knapp gesagt alles aber seht
selbst für dieses video zum beispiel
wurde hayek total gefeiert ein instagram
video das finden wir journalistinnen und
journalisten nicht wirklich toll denn
damit entziehen sich politiker ja
unseren kritischen fragen aber trotzdem
ist das ganz klar ein neuer
kommunikationsstil war sehr sehr auf
benutzt ihren bh am zweiten tag eine
reise die irgendwie total merkwürdig ist
in der ukraine sterben die menschen und
hier seht ihr ja wie die skyline ist
aber es ist die ukraine krise die mich
hierher gebracht hat und der versuch
möglichst schnell von russischem gas und
öl und kohle runterzukommen in diesem
fall vor allem gas und eine neue
energiepolitik für deutschland und für
europa aufzubauen
katar ist natürlich eine politisch sagen
wir interessante region das sich immer
angesprochen habe sind die arbeits und
menschenrechte die natürlich ein großes
thema sind es gibt nur 300.000 kataris
zehn prozent der bevölkerung drei
millionen menschen leben hier der rest
arbeitet hier häufig nicht so ganz guten
bedingungen ich hatte ein bisschen sorge
ist das wohl wenn ich das in your face
ansprechen ob ich dann rausgeworfen
werde aber so war es überhaupt nicht die
katarische regierung hat das aufgenommen
sie wusste dass es kommen würde und sie
hat sich da auch klar zu bekannt was
aber auch ganz gut kann nötig da springt
ja viel zu kanzler mal eben auf dem
tisch spender gesehen und gehört werden
will wie hier neulich zb beim besuch
einer raffinerie in schwedt und bei uns
im zdf im heute journal wurde er neulich
gefragt was er von einer energie spar
premier hält das leute also geld zurück
kriegen wenn sie sich anstrengen beim
energiesparen antwort habe es ist ja
keinen spaß den wir haben sondern das
ist eine ernste politische
gesellschaftspolitische situation und
wenn wir da uns nicht gegenseitig helfen
kommen wir da nicht durch werden der
jenaer jemand sagt ich helfe nur wenn
ich noch mal 50 euro krieg würde ich
sagen die christlich alter
sagte bundeswirtschaftsminister
da muss auch meine kollegin marietta
slomka ein bisschen versteckt lachen
robert habeck und annalena baerbock sind
also die vorbilder in sachen
kommunikation in diesem kabinett das
barometer bei uns im zdf gegen sie vor
stolz wie stark das mit ihrer art
zusammenhängt zu kommunizieren schwer zu
sagen aber er stellt sich noch eine
andere frage stehen sie für eine
zeitenwende stehen robert habeck und
annalena baerbock dafür dass politiker
in zukunft anders sprechen mit uns zu
uns zur presse ja man wenn man sich
jetzt noch kevin kühnert anschaut könnte
man tatsächlich zu dieser zu diesem
schluss kommen aber wenn man sich auf
der anderen seite lars klingbeil wenn
man sich hendrik wüst wenn man sich
kretschmann sachsen anschaut wenn man
sich günter in schleswig holstein im
anschaut dann würde ich die er in der
nähe von oder scholz erkennt kommen ihre
art weil es jetzt in der nähe von roland
harich also von daher jetzt eine klare
trendwende
generationswechsel auch im politischen
stil kann ich das noch nicht erkennen
wir fassen zusammen salz kann das aber
irgendwie nur ab und zu mal habeck kann
sma im moment jedenfalls was aber auch
zur wahl gehört um auch wirklich fair zu
bleiben stolz es kanzler habeck nicht
was sicherlich ein großer unterschied
ist robert habeck hat das wichtige aber
überschaubare thema der
energiesicherheit dann gerade wofür er
verantwortlich ist und was gerade im
öffentlichen fokus ist wohl es geht es
um fragen von krieg und frieden
und da ist natürlich auch die
internationale aufmerksamkeit ist noch
mal eine ganz andere
trotz alledem olaf scholz hat ein
problem was meint ihr was kann er tun
soll er mehr fehler wagen könnte es dann
besser klappen würdet ihr euch dann zum
beispiel besser regiert fühlen schreibt
es in die kommentare
und wenn es euch gefallen hat dann lasst
ein leichter und abonniert uns danke
dafür danke fürs zuschauen und bis zum
nächsten mal bei insight politics